c'est l'une des toutes dernières
révélations de la sphère benalla après
son licenciement en juillet dernier
l'ancien chargé de mission à l'elysée
aurait utilisé illégalement ces
passeports diplomatiques afin de
faciliter ses voyages à l'étranger une
information délivrée mercredi par le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république
nous savons aujourd'hui que monsieur
benalla à utiliser presque une vingtaine
de fois ces passeports entre le 1er août
2010 8 et le 31 décembre
depuis alex honnold bella a été placé en
garde à vue jeudi et présenté à un juge
vendredi un magistrat qui a décidé de le
mettre en examen pour usage public et
sans droits d'un document justificatif
d'une qualité professionnelle sur les
chefs d'abus de confiance de faux et
usage de faux documents administratifs
et d'obtention indue de documents
administratifs
il est placé sous le statut de témoin
assisté une ligne de crête se dessine
désormais dans les travaux de la
commission denquête car alexandre
benalla pourrait refuser de commenter
tous les faits qui relèvent des
poursuites judiciaires en vertu de la
séparation des pouvoirs
mais pas de quoi inquiéter les
co-rapporteurs je ne ferai pas le début
du commencement d'un commentaire sur la
garde à vue c'est une décision de
justice
en revanche nous faisons notre travail
de parlementaires des sénateurs qui
entendent donc se concentrer sur les
dysfonctionnements à l'elysée pour
éviter toute ingérence avec la sphère
judiciaire